It's the end of an era for the internet.
After a year-long process and about 4.5 billion dollars,...
...Verizon has officially closed its acquisition of Yahoo.
The deal between Verizon and Yahoo was announced last year in July,...
...after months of negotiation.
Even after the deal was made, Yahoo's selling price went down 250 million dollars,...
...after a string of security breaches.
As part of the deal, Yahoo will now be a part of Verizon's new media subsidiary Oath,...
...which includes HuffPost, AOL and Tumblr.
And Marissa Mayer, CEO of Yahoo since 2012,...
...said Tuesday on Tumblr she would resign.
She'll receive a 23-million-dollar severance package.
Since she took control in 2012, the company did more than triple its stock price...
...and Mayer noted that in her goodbye post...
...but Yahoo made cuts to its workforce last year and more are expected this year.
This Friday, the remainder of Yahoo will be renamed Altaba.